hi everyone this is Jerry and this is a
live blitz game okay this is a game
against primo SOF I'm just gonna go for
the little Carl Kahn I tend to play this
quite a bit it's one of the more passive
type of openings this is the advanced
variation pawn to e5 just trying to get
my bishop outside of my eventual pawn
chain pawn to e6 is going to be coming
up there's pawn g4 here there's Knight
f3 knight c6 usually g4 is played down
Bishop back and then you see knight
Knight GTE - this Bishop kind of gets
harassed quite a bit yeah this Knight
pivots on e - and then comes to f4 h6 is
often needed otherwise there's some h4
type of moves that come about
h6 is an important point I need to be
able to tuck my bishop away on h7
because these pawns are fixed in this
manner I'm looking to play to c5 at some
point to strike at the d4 pawn right now
this is considered to be the the base of
the white pawn structure
Bishop out maybe here Knight here it's
kind of it's a bit awkward to try and
develop my Kings side as a result of
this pawn being on e5 because the most
natural square for my knight is to come
to f6 but this pawns regarding it now h4
not sure if h4 is appropriate here if I
play h5 now this Knight comes to f4 and
it's it's a bit annoying because it's
hitting both h5 and g6 I think I just
placed c5 here strike at this pawn c5
strike at d4 and then follow up at night
c6 not really thinking like a ton of
moves deep here usually if you try to
think too far ahead you find that just
like 2 moves into it a lot of that the
calculations you were doing is for
naught I'm just focused on maybe trying
to make the best move or 2 moves in
advance and that's about it it's rare
that I'm able to anticipate what the
position is like 3 moves down the line
thinking he might come to g2 with his
bishop or maybe even III putting
pressure in directly on the c5 pawn if
he just takes I just recapture my bishop
and he's he is as a result helped
develop one of my pieces he should
probably avoid taking here you should
probably play bishop here maybe even
night here if he plays Knight here I'll
tuck my bishop back yeah I just move my
bishop back now there's this could be a
point where he could maybe just do a
piece sacrifice right now both both
Knights are focused here and maybe even
the bishop could come here and there
might be some sac going on alright so
there's there's two pieces hitting this
pawn on c5 his pawn directly and Bishop
indirectly I think it just I think I
just take pawn takes pawn and then
follow up with Knight to c6
I don't think there's anything better
or maybe just knight c6 right away
that's one thing that's a pretty good to
consider in your own games if you're if
you're anticipating let's say capturing
upon and then following up at Knight to
c6 oftentimes if you switch the order it
might turn out to be better so maybe
instead of pawn takes pawn in knight c6
maybe knight c6 and threaten pawn takes
pawn so just switching the move order
might turn out to be better actually I
think that knight c6 might be best
because if pawn takes pawn then I could
push d4 and I'd be forking the bishop
and Knight hmm yeah I'm gonna go for
that 96 if he takes I push forward and
I'd be forking the bishop and Knight on
one material I think pawn takes is bad
here he's his his center is being put
under there's a lot of pressure being
put on his center how did he has to
maybe support this square with the
knight
it seems to be a bit awkward I'm feeling
pretty good at this point in the game
he's a lot lower rated than me but I
think he's you know judging by his play
here I think he's actually much better
than this rating
so he can't really if he wants to
develop this Bishop he'd have to come
here this Bishop would indirectly
influence the central squares right now
my knight is focused on these two
squares I planned the bishop here
the bishop temporarily takes my knight
out of the game he's already getting
very low on time this game might not
even reach an endgame phase okay
Queen here preparing the queenside
castle this is a good move
I think pawn takes Bishop takes Knight
takes then I have to worry about my
bishop coming out here let's see I'm
thinking do I go ahead and take
recapture Knight takes and then bring my
knight to e7 and then c6 or die play my
knight here first so once again I'm
questioning the move order
I play Knight here first because this
this threat of the fork is still in the
air if I play Knight G to e7 if pawn
takes pawn just pawn push and then I
think I'd be doing pretty good I'm gonna
go for hmm actually if I play Knight G
to e7 he might play Knight here because
it's an I play Knight G to e7 my d6
square is no longer defended by my
bishop so this night might be able to
pivot on b5 and then hop on d6 might be
a bit awkward for me I'll take first
because I didn't like the I didn't like
the idea of this night being able to
come here and then here all right I'm
gonna take Queen takes and then Knight
to these two No
they'd hear and then to see sex if he
checks me I'd block with my bishop and
no actually I could have taken this pawn
right but that's really not something I
was considering at that point because I
was more concerned about my King safety
my bishop being I'm sort of like the the
Kings side of the board here well not
sort of he is on the Kings side but
being over here I have to watch my light
squares on the Queen side as a result
okay so the Queen here anticipating my
knight coming here he probably I think I
might have been better to first wait for
my knight to come here because I mean
right now he already told me like a move
sooner the address for his queen okay
just not here seems natural attacking
this pawn making way for my bishop to
come out I think I think I'm clearly
better at this point
pressure on this pawn I have a I have
the bishop pair this is usually an asset
this would be I'm pretty sure this would
be considered an asset in this position
because it's an open position and
bishops function well in open positions
so what to do about this pawn here I
mean I don't even have to go ahead and
capture a pin in there Knight
it's a developing move this is a good
move he's probably still gonna go Queen
side with these two pawns having
advanced King side casting probably
won't be the greatest I think I'll do
similar develop my bishop and pose some
problems he has three pieces on this
diagonal so that could be a bit awkward
for him to get out of Bishop takes
recapture the Queen now I'm getting
ready to just take the knight and grab
this pawn actually I have to worry about
my pawn here do I take the knight do I
play here I think I play here first I
think he might be in some trouble I'm
ready to just win a piece here because
my rook is indirectly pinning his pawn
to his King so right now it's really
yeah Punda spun to c5 now pawn to c5
halt by d4 he really can't chase my
bishop away with them like eight three
because I could just take my bishop all
right I'm gonna end up winning a piece
here because once again this pawn is
indirectly pinned to the king so soon my
bishop moves this pawn is essentially
powerless so I could take twice on this
square my bishop is yeah this is he's in
rough shape now I think it's pretty much
just a matter winning the game from here
just coming down to so you can move
quick means getting harassed my queen
keeps getting harassed just gonna double
on the V file here I kept free move
just trying to crash through at this
point he's gonna get made it oh alright
well that was a that was a fairly good
game again this this guy's rating wasn't
you know the highest but I think he
played a very good game nevertheless so
that's all for this video I hope you got
something out of it
rating and commenting as always I
appreciate it thanks so much bye